- I've heard you have had dwindlings
or little rumors of a presidential run?
(Mark giggles)
- No.
- No?
- No chance.
- No chance?
- None, none.
How could you put your kids through that?
I could never put my children
through all the grief that happens
in a political campaign.
Just not gonna happen, no.
I actually considered it at one point
and we had a family vote.
We did have a family vote.
- So I'm not crazy?
- Well,
- I mean, I know I am, but,
(Mark and audience giggle)
you've thought about it?
- There's five in our family
and the vote was four to one,
I was the only yes.
So, yeah, the family doesn't agree,
it just can't happen.
- I totally appreciate that.
(audience applauds)
That's why you'd make make
such a great president!
(Mark giggles)
Okay, well, now, I was curious,
I was watching "Inventing Anna."
- Oh, I love that show.
It's just insane.
(audience applauds)
It's just the craziest thing ever.
- How does one pull off
getting people to invest and convince,
who is a complete fraud?
How do we Svengali our way into this?
What do you see when you
see a show like that?
- She made one big mistake.
You can't steal.
That's the one thing you can't do.
You can fake it till you make it,
but when she was ripping off the hotels,
when she would refuse to
pay back the credit card
for her friend,
if she had not done that,
she woulda ended up being in a great spot,
because even though she
didn't get her 281 Park
or whatever it was,
and she didn't create her club,
and whether or not that was
a good idea, I don't know,
but everything else she did
was just networking and learning
and putting yourself in
a position to succeed.
And if she just had not ripped people off,
she'd be having conversations
with those same people saying,
"You know what, that first thing,
the club didn't work,
but let's talk about this",
and she'd have great
relationships with them.
But when you try to steal,
when you actually steal from somebody,
you go to jail and that's
exactly what she deserved.
- And the karmic ladder, you cannot climb.
- You cannot climb that ladder, right?
The karma, payback's a bitch,
and she she faced it.
- Well, you are a favorite shark,
everybody loves you on that show,
it's so fun to watch you,
you learn, you get excited,
but gosh, if I have
this opportunity to ask,
what is one of your favorite
gets on "Shark Tank"?
And what is the one that got away?
- The one that got away was,
oh my goodness, Spikeball.
People on the beach are always
playing, throwing it around,
its great exercise,
and they wanted to create a
league, a Spikeball league,
and have me be the commissioner.
I did not want to be the commissioner
of the Spikeball league,
so that one got away
and they just blew up.
One that I got that I'm really proud of
was a company called Cycloramic,
and what they did was, back
when the iPhone 5 was out,
they had an app
that when you put it on a
flat surface and started it,
it would take these panoramic pictures.
And I just thought that was really cool.
It became the number
one app in the app store
when "Shark Tank" aired,
and then iPhone changed
what it looked like,
so you couldn't just stand it up.
So these guys had to pivot,
and they pivoted into something called
computer vision software,
and they turned into this
huge, enormous success.
- Speaking of apps, I was
watching "Super Pumped."
(Mark laughs)
The battle for Uber starring
Joseph Gordon-Levitt,
everybody get ready for
our next favorite show,
by the way.
- Amazing.
- It's so good.
Amazing, yep.
"Super Pumped" is great.
- You're in it.
- Yeah, I made my little appearance.
- [Drew] Yes!
- Yeah.
- Is it true that you have
had anything to do with Uber
at one point or were considering it,
and then,
- Considered.
So Travis, the guy who started Uber,
- [Drew] Travis Kalanick?
- Kalanick, yeah.
So he had a company, Red
Swoosh, that I invested in.
Then he comes to me with Uber
and I was one of the very first people,
it was called Uber Cab,
and Travis and I had this
love-hate relationship,
so I'm like, "Travis, I love the idea,
but you're gonna have all these problems,
da, da, da, da, da,
you're not raising enough
money, da, da, da, da, da."
And I went "Shark Tank" on 'em,
and didn't like the valuation.
And he was like, "Fine",
and never called me back.
So I had a chance
to be one of the very
first investors in Uber
and I missed it.
- Okay, so there is a potential guy here
who might be "Shark Tank" material.
Would you be so kind as to,
after the break, come
and meet him with me,
and see what his invention is?
- For you, Drew, I'll do anything.
- [Drew] Including run for
president one day with me?
- Almost anything.
- Okay.
All right, we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)